c'est pour eux une routine quasiment
quotidiennes à quelques pas de la maison
se trouve leur seul magasin de proximité
un carrefour contact
vers 10h jeu deschamps et je vais chez
contact je vais même même quelques
courges déjà plutôt quatrième dans
l'immeuble et balades à pied toujours
afin que vous remplissez pas loin
jacques la rue à traverser
sauf que désormais pour faire ses
courses il pourrait bien devoir se
rendre un kilomètre plus loin d'ici la
fin du mois de juin le magasin contact
pourrait bien disparaître et de plus
affiché ses couleurs
ce qu'il nous faut c'est un petit
magasin pour le dépannage ne serait ce
que pour lui celle du poivron valent des
bricoles le peu de clients du magasin se
pose donc aujourd'hui cette même
question comment faire sans leurs
commerces de proximité mais on sait pas
on ne sait pas nous on pense se faire
emmener ailleurs quoi mais faudra qu'on
trouvait un moyen fort c'est pas
vraiment pas facile dans ce magasin on
se prépare à la faim depuis deux mois
déjà
ici les stocks s'amoindrissent et les
dix salariés pensent déjà à leur
reconversion
sur l'ensemble du groupe seul 195
salariés sont d'ores et déjà assurés de
garder leur emploi
l'entreprise assure qu' au moins mille
autres salariés seront reclassés
ce sont en tout 249 magasins qui devrait
être fermée 1850 postes sont donc
concernées par une suppression
ici la mairie préfère ne pas trop
s'avancer sur ce dossier pour l'instant
la discrétion est de mise mais le maire
de la ville mère l'est républicain alain
suguenot nous l'a assuré il est en ce
moment même en discussions avec un
éventuel repreneur
les dix salariés de carrefour contact
devrait donc être fixés sur leur sort
dans les prochains jours